من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
اسامه قاسم اسامه اهلا بك معنا هل يمكن ان
تطلعنا على الحاله التنظيميه خاصه في هذه
الساعات في الحرم المكي
اهلا وسهلا تحيه طيبه لكم لجميع مشاهدين
قناه العربيه من جديد انقل لكم الصوت
والصوره اليوم من اعلى نقطه في توسعه
الملك فهد هنا في الحرم المكي الشريف
اترككم الان في صوره حول هذه التوسعه في
اعلى نقطه في هذه التوسعه ويظهر امامنا
ايضا سطوح التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه
بالتاكيد رئاسه شؤون الحرمين قامت بفتح
اماكن اكبر لاستيعاب اعداد كبيره جدا من
المصلين والمعتبرين في شهر رمضان المبارك
بعد ان وصلت اعداد الزوار والمعتمرين
قرابه الثمانيه مليون زائر ومعتمر
بالتاكيد انها في الايام القادمه ستشهد
ازديدا كبيرا نشهد اليوم ايضا فتح هذا
المطاف او هذا المكان للصلاه وايضا مصلى
مصليات في توسعه توسعه السعوديه الثالثه
في السطوح وهي خطوه تاتي ضمن الخطه
التشغيليه لرئاسه شؤون الحرمين الاستيعاب
اكبر عدد ممكن من المصلين والزائرين
بالتاكيد ايضا ان هذه الخطوه اتت
لاستيعابهم وايضا للتوسع اكبر خصوصا ان
العشره الوسطى والعشره الاواخر ايضا ستشهد
تواجد وتوافد كبير جدا من المصلين
والمعتمرين ايضا وهذا ما دعى رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين لفتى هذه المساحات الكبيره جدا
لاداء الصلاه اليوم نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره
جدا بالامس كان 7.4 مليون زائر ومعتمر
خلال تسعه ايام هذه الاعداد بالتاكيد
قابله للزياده خلال الايام القادمه من
المحتمل ان تصل الاعداد الزوار والمعتمرين
في شهر رمضان المبارك لهذا العام الى 30
مليون زائر بالنسبه للخطه التشغيليه
المتواجده في الحرم المكي الشريف اليوم
ايضا كل الاماكن المتواجده في الحرم المكي
الشريفه من المطاف المسعى المصليات
العلويه المصليات في التوسعه السعوديه
الثالثه ممتلئه بالكامل من اليوم الاول
وبالتاكيد ستشهد ازديا كبيرا في الايام
القادمه شكرا لك اسامه قاسم كنت معي من
مكه المكرمه